this talk is by metheus's olympia uh on
connections between geometry polynomials
and quantum partition functions
all right thanks for inviting uh so this
is based on a joint work with uh aram
harrell and sayed mehraban
uh so this talk is about interacting
quantum systems
where you have n quantum spins
on a lattice or a bounded degree graph
these spins interact with each other and
since in physics
interactions are short range uh
basically
each single spin effectively only
interacts with its
surrounding neighbors so we assume the
system
uh is at some fixed temperature and uh
you'll
leave it to evolve and the spins
interact with each other and eventually
reach an equilibrium state so
uh in physics and quantum computing
uh this is like a central problem we
would like to understand the properties
of the systems
and in particular we want to have
approximation algorithms that given the
description of where these
spins are and how they interact with
each other
uh it estimates the certain properties
of them
so the typical thing that we would like
to know about these systems is their
partition function
and in the rest of the topic i'll
basically tell you
ways that you can look at these systems
from the
lens of computational complexity and
approximation algorithms
uh before giving you more details about
what quantum systems are
let me begin with uh classical spin
systems which is something probably most
people are familiar with
so here we assign we have the graph and
we assign
binary plus minus one variables to the
vertices of the graph
and then for an overall configuration of
these spins there is a
cost associated with them in physics we
call this cost function the hamiltonian
and the specific cost of like one of
these configurations is called the
energy
of that spin configuration so the
hamiltonian is sum of local terms
for example it could be that like in the
case of icing model or hardcore model
each each of these local terms look at
the
spin of connected you know
vertices and assign a plus minus one a
plus minus a j i j
coefficient into them depending on
whether it's agree or disagree
and there is a probability distribution
that
describes the state of this system uh
at some fixed temperature t that we
usually work with its inverse beta
so one of these spin configuration is a
tank with a probability which is
proportional to e to the minus
inverse temperature times the energy of
that specific configuration
and then there is a normalization factor
called the partition function
which is some of these exponential
factors so the partition function is not
merely a
normalization factor it also encodes uh
useful
statistical properties of these spin
systems or the combinatorial information
about them
and both in physics and tcs uh it's like
a well-studied problem to
evaluate the partition function of this
system
so i'm going to introduce some notation
and like
express everything that i had in this
slide in a slightly different language
in terms of matrices and linear algebra
and that's because it it's much easier
to uh extend that to
a quantum space instead later so now
instead of assigning plus minus one
variables to vertices
i'm going to assign vectors so it's
either one zero vector or a zero one
vector so there's a like a two
dimensional uh
complex vector space but i only assign
the basis
vectors uh in this vector space to the
vertices
and i put a notation on the spins here
to distinguish it from what i had in the
previous
and then uh similarly a general
configuration of
uh all these ns pins is a vector
uh with two to the n entries and it's
just because there are
that many possibilities uh
one thing else that i uh i do is that i
put all these uh
costs for different configurations on
the diagonal entries of a matrix
so for example if i have like just two
spins
then i form a diagonal matrix with all
the possible
weights that i would assign to these two
two spins
so there is a more convenient way of
writing
this four by four matrix in terms of the
tensor product of
uh two by two matrices so this z here is
just a
matrix with plus minus one minus
diagonal and the index
i or j is just telling uh which uh which
vertex this this is
this matrix is uh assigned to um so you
can check that each like uh
the left-hand side and the right-hand
side are equal
and then since the hamiltonian of all
these spins is just
some of these local uh weights i can
just write it
uh like that and there is a tensor
identity
over all other spins that are usually
done right in the rest of the type for
this simplicity
and then similarly i'll put all the
probabilities in the gibbs distribution
on the diagonal entries of a matrix
and this can be written as a matrix
exponential
so this matrix rho is just e to the
minus beta times the
diagonal matrix that i just designed
and with this notation the partition
function is just the trace of this
matrix exponential
so so far i haven't really done anything
i've just promoted everything we had in
the previous
slide two diagonal matrices or vectors
but when we go to quantum spin systems
this becomes a
non-trivial and in particular
there we assign uh
any linear combination of these vectors
to uh to the
to the vertices and we just for
simplicity assume these vectors are
normalized
so it's not just any more like one of
these
one zero or zero one vectors could be
any linear combination of
and this is called superposition in
quantum mechanics
and then similarly uh the state of all
spin
is not one of the basis vectors among
the two to the n
two to the n possible vectors just like
any linear combination of
and uh in particular there are vectors
in this linear combination that
cannot be written as a tensor product of
two-dimensional vectors
and uh this this is called entanglement
uh and a simple example of that is like
if you have again two spins and then
their state is just like
one zero zero one then you can't write
it as like a single uh tensor product
you need to add at least uh
at least two of them so this is like
kind of different from the previous
picture that we assign
uh meaningful spins to each vertex and
then the overall configuration is just
like a
collection of this
and then the hamiltonian is defined as
before
it's now a general hermitian matrix
2 to the n by 2 to the n matrix but it's
a still local so it's sum of
logarithmical terms
but now these are these terms which we
assigned to
the edges for example need not
commute with each other and an example
of that
is uh the following interactions
this is like very common in physics so
these are
what i had in the previous slides and x
and y's are just
other matrices with plus minus one
eigenvalues
but they're not diagonal in the same
basis as z
uh and then a and b and c's are just
like arbitrary uh
uh coefficients so now if i look at the
these hijs of adjacent edges
they don't necessarily commute and as we
i'll describe later this uh this
complicates like studying
this quantum system
and instead of gibbs distribution now we
have it gives a state which is defined
uh as before in terms of the matrix
exponential in terms of the
hamiltonian and it's just again a
general uh
psd hermitian operator so we usually
call this density matrix for density
operator in quantum mechanics
and that gives us and the partition
function is trace of
the matrix exponential so as i said
before this partition function is
basically
what we we would like to approximate and
once we have that then we can like get
physical uh properties of the system
that we would like to
estimate but uh
exactly evaluating the partition
function is known to be sharpie hard
what we really want is the approximation
algorithm that given
the description of this hamiltonian the
inverse temperature beta and an
error familiar epsilon gives you an
epsilon additive error to the log of the
partition function
so natural question is how hard it is to
[Music]
approximate the partition the log of the
partition function
and this turns out to depend on the
temperature or
beta that you want to evaluate the
partition function at so this is a
widely aesthetic problem classically let
me
first review what we know there so in
two extreme cases it's uh
it's easy to see this temperature
dependence of the
computational hardness of approximating
the partition function
at very high temperatures meaning very
small beta
but the gibbs distribution is just a
uniform distribution evaluating
partition function is trivial at a very
high temperature at very low
temperatures meaning very large beta
this problem basically reduces to like a
max csp which is npr
so as you see by uh changing the
temperature the hardness goes from being
trivial to np-hard
but we also know about the another
transition uh
as we change the temperature from
physics perspective which is a
transition in the phase of the system or
thermal phase transition where for
example we can go from a disordered
phase to an ordered phase and at a very
critical value of beta
the properties of the system abruptly
change so there are various ways to
characterize these uh these phases
uh one is based on the decay of
correlations and one is based on complex
zeros of partition function
um so these are this this uh picture of
physical phase translation is closely
related to
uh the transition in the computational
hardness
and for example we know that mixing
in time is equivalent to mixing in a
space where mixing in time means uh
there are efficient
microphone mono color algorithms to
sample from the gibbs distribution and
estimate the partitioning function
and mixing in a space just means you
have exponential decay of correlations
in the system so if you assume one
of them then you get the other one which
is what happens in the high temperature
phase
uh depicted above we also have direct
ways of getting deterministic algorithms
by using the correlation decay
and on the other hand we know that it's
np hard to
estimate the partition function in the
below the phase transition point
and recently there is a new method for
evaluating a partition function based on
the other characteristics of the high
temperature regime which is based on the
complex zeros of the partition function
is due to barbara
and then other people have applied it to
icing model and hardware model
and i'll uh i'll describe how we can
basically use the same method in the
quantum setting
uh so okay this was all about classical
systems but how about quantum system
so as i said there are various
complications there
and one is that uh the terms in the
hamiltonian
don't commute with each other so this
makes simple things like writing
uh e to the h one plus h two as uh the
product of
e to the h1 times e to the h2 uh this
doesn't hold anymore
uh and this like uh causes like a direct
uh
extension of various uh classical
methods to uh
not be possible and like
uh it makes quantum systems to violate
uh like basic properties of the spin
systems class calls being systems like
the markup property
and even if you restrict yourself to
commuting hamiltonians meaning you
assume
your hamiltonian is a sum of terms that
mutually commute with each other
uh then you can diagonalize all these in
the same basis but the problem is that
the joint eigenvectors were
for these matrices they still can be
entangled so even for commuting
hamiltonians uh problem is not uh
reducible to directly reducible to class
calls from systems
and in terms of hardness uh estimating
the
uh the eigenvalues of the hamiltonian
which is
the equivalent of like uh max csps
is qma hard even on a one-dimensional
chain in the quantum thing so qma is the
quantum analog of mp
but on the other hand we we don't have
uh quantum versions of uh
pcps probability checkable proofs for
for these hamiltonians
and this also like uh makes establishing
hard business
hardness uh results harder but uh
despite all these complications there
has been also
uh progress on studying this system
uh so as before uh
the two extreme cases uh for quantum
system is the same side very high
temperature is trivial to find the
partition function
at very low temperature uh it's a
np qm may hurt if beta is polynomially
large and this is because as i said we
don't have uh quantum pcps
or np-hard if uh if beta is a constant
and from physics perspective we still
have the same picture there is a thermal
phase transition for quantum system
and the high temperature phase is
characterized by
uh the dedicated correlations or complex
zeros
and certain classical results have been
uh extended to quantum settings for
example one direction of
the prevalence between mixing and time
and mixing in space
um has been established by brandel and
castroyanov for
commuting hamiltonians so mixing in time
here means there is a
efficient quantum circuit for sampling
from the given state
and mixing in time is a a quantum
version of decay of correlations uh
and they've also extended their results
to the general case the non-commuting
hamiltonian case if we further assume
that the markov property
an approximate version of markup
property holds for quantum system so
as i said this is like something that is
uh a unique property of class calls and
system and it's always true
uh it's conjecture that for quantum
systems uh an approximate version of
that hole but uh
so far it hasn't been proven
but we also know that there are there is
a family of
quantum hamiltonians called sign free or
stoquastic hamiltonians
whose partition function can be directly
mapped to a classical uh
partition function and then you can
apply like existing monte carlo message
to evaluate the classical partition
function and hence get an approximation
for the quantity
this is done by brave where are gossip
the cross on heroin others
and as i said there is a new method for
evaluating the partition function based
on the complex zero and in this talk
i'll show you
how this this method can be naturally
also extended
to quantum spin systems
all right so before going on let me give
you a brief overview of the
the result that i'll cover so first i'll
tell you how we can get algorithms from
complex zeros uh and then i'll talk
about the
connection between these complex zeros
and decay of correlations for
quantum distance system
so let's start with the zeros so similar
to classical
uh partition functions quantum
quantitation functions for real
uh beta very inverse temperature
uh it's just a sum of a strictly
positive terms so on real axis there are
no singularities for
the log of the partition function but
this changes if you look at complex uh
betas and in particular in the limit of
the number of particles or spin going to
infinity
uh some of these uh in certain locations
uh beta could be zero and these zeros
can approach the real axis
uh and uh get closer and closer
at the critical value of beta which is
basically where phase transition occurs
so at around this point the log of the
partition function is non-analytic
and it causes its derivatives and other
physical uh quantities
uh to blow up and that's like a
one signature of uh thermal phase
transition
uh so studying these zeros has been
initiated
by lee and young in a slightly different
context and then
uh extended to the setup of thermal
phase transition by fischer
so our first result shows that as long
as
you want to evaluate the partition
function at the beta which is less than
this critical point
meaning it's in what's called uh
analysis analyticity region
then there is a quasi polynomial
algorithm for uh
approximately
and the what do i mean by an electricity
region it basically means uh there is a
region
of constant uh widths and legs that
includes
uh beta equal zero uh the infinite
temperature point
uh such that there are no complex zeros
uh inside this region
uh so if we have such a reason then the
log of the partition function is
analytic
but we also assume that the absolute
value of log is
bounded by order and inside this region
so uh for classical spin system since
they're polynomial since the partition
function is a polynomial in terms of
beta
uh we we don't need to assume this but
uh
in general this is not true for quantum
systems so
we need to have this assumption i'll
i'll talk about that later
so if uh if the inner temperature beta
that we want to evaluate the
partition function at is inside such a
zero free radian
then there's a simple algorithm for
estimating the partition function it's
just
you uh use truncated taylor expansion
at beta equals zero and then
if you want inverse polynomial error
that means you need to
only keep the order login
first terms in the expansion which means
you need to compute
the order and order log and
derivatives uh so computing
these the derivatives of the log of the
partition function can be reduced to
uh finding the derivatives of the
partition function itself this is
similar to what happens classically
and uh the case derivative of the
partition function at beta equals zero
is just
the trace of hamiltonian to the case bar
so remember that the hamiltonian was sum
of order n
uh local matrices so its case power is
also
sum of terms but now uh they're into the
order k many terms
and these h prime i is act on uh further
k
minister so if k is
uh order log n
estimating this uh these local traces
can be done in polynomial time and since
they're
into the order k of them the overall
running time is just
into the order login which is quasi
quality
so you can actually do better and reduce
the running time to just the polynomial
time
by using things like cluster expansions
uh all right so that's uh
the first result it just shows that as
long as you're in the
zeroth region the truncated taylor
expansion approach just naturally
extends the climaxes
but how do we actually approve the
existence of citrine
so we show that there exists a disk
which is free of these zeros
around beta equals zero with a radius
spade or not which basically
scales as one over the degree of the
interaction graph
and the baby proof is by is by
recursively lower bounding in a
partition function
using what's called the cluster
expansion
uh so this cluster expansion is one way
to
get around this problem of having a
non-commuted hamiltonian it's not the
only way
and our proof idea is the following we
compare the partition function before
and
after adding one spin to a subset of the
spins
so i forget about all the interactions
uh uh
so i consider a subset of ls space and i
forget about all the
interactions uh between other spins
and we show that the partition function
after adding this new spin
is lower bounded by a constant times the
partition function
before adding this and once you iterate
over
this then you just get an exponentially
small lower bound on the overall
partition function
and this just means the log of the
partition function
uh is its absolute value is bounded by
the order n
which is what we needed uh for the
truncated taylor expansion in the
previous slide
so question uh yep yeah so does this
require that the graph is uh
like amenable or is like a lattice not
growing too fast
no you as long as it's just a bounded
degree graph uh uh
it suffices i i don't need i don't need
it to be allowed it's just for
simplicity i i
assume that here
all right uh so how do we show this
lower bound on the
uh partition function after we add a
spin that's where we use the cluster
expansion so
uh if you've seen them how uh how they
work uh for class collision systems it's
similar in the quantum settings but
there are subtleties because
as i said the local terms don't come you
then you need to be careful how you
prove the convergence but basically
these uh
cluster expansions allow you to expand
the
matrix exponential in terms of this sum
of
the product of the local terms and this
holds as long as your beta is inside
that
convergence disk so once you have this
then you can
single out the effect of adding one spin
to the partition function
so write the new one as the old one plus
some corrections but then you can
show it's the corrections are basically
small
and then this this gives you the
delaware
uh all right so these are the the
algorithmic results
uh let me know if you have any any
questions
so one more one more question so can you
um
can you also show something like that
correlation so that the
the critical activity for correlation
decay and for the zeros are
same in this context in the quantum uh
yeah i'll talk about that uh
in our next result okay
uh all right so let me move on and yeah
we're now i'm going to talk about the
the connection between the zeros and
correlation decay
so again the picture here is not as
complete as what we have classically
uh so for clients constant systems
by decalculations uh like one way to
characterize the
correlation is to look at the covariance
between spins
so we assume we have like two subsets of
spins that are disjoint at some
distance away from each other and then
we look at the covariance between the
spins in region a and b
and as long as this covariance decays
exponentially with the distance we call
the the
gibbs distribution to have uh the decay
of correlation property
so the definition of decay of
correlation is similar for for quantum
systems
there is also uh some differences
uh so now we consider
any hermitian operator o a and ob that
that are acting uh on a spinning region
a and b
and uh instead of give distribution we
also have the gibbs
state and instead of that covariance we
have for classical spin systems now we
consider a similar expression for these
matrices
so as long as oaob and rho are
all diagonal in the same basis this
basically reduces to what we had
with the class of covariance but in
general these
are just uh arbitrary uh hermitian
matrices you know they don't need to be
diagonal in the same place
uh and this is because the way
measurements work in quantum mechanics
they have observables and
uh uh the the baby have access to
correlations
is through these uh permission operators
and we say that the quantum gives state
as the decay of correlation property if
the
this correlation on the left-hand side
is decaying exponentially with the
distance
so classically the relation between the
correlations and
complex zeros has been studied
it's proven for translationally in
variant classical systems
that these two uh seemingly different
ways of talking about the phase
transition are actually equally valid
and
this is by the russian initiative and
there's been
an extension of that to various systems
uh
that i i don't get into the data
but how are quantum systems uh so we
show one direction of this
uh in certain cases so we show that
uh for the inverse temperature betas
that there are no complex zeros uh
around it
the decay of correlation holds
and this is when the spins that or the
regions that we are looking at
are at least logarithmically far away
from each other
or when the hamiltonian consists of
commuting terms
or when your strings are arranged on a
one dimensional chain so if
you remember i said the one-dimensional
chain in quantum
case is not like trivial it could be in
general
qma heart
so the idea of the proof is similar to
the extra the truncation the
truncated taylor expansion that i
mentioned before
what we do is that we define a function
f of beta
that measures the correlations between
uh spins in
region a and b so this is similar to
that covariance thing
uh i wrote for quantum systems in the
previous slide
but it's uh changed a little bit and
like
uh it's modified to have certain
properties
but it's the case that if this function
is a small
then the correlations or the covariance
i wrote in the previous
slide is also small so again without
loss of generally just look at this
so we show that uh at beta equals zero
meaning at infinite temperature this
function is zero
so this makes sense because there uh the
given state is just a uniform
distribution there is no correlation
between this
but not only that we also show that the
low order derivatives of
this function are also zero and the
number of these uh
derivatives scales with the distance
between the regions that we are
measuring their correlation the further
the part they are
the more of these derivatives are zero
and we also show that if at that beta
the log of the partition function is
analytic there are no complex zeros
around it
then this function f of beta is also
analytic
so this function looks very flat near
the origin
and it's also analytic so then we can
use complex
analysis tools to show that it doesn't
blow up or anything if you
go to a constant data the value of the
function remains a small
and as i said the function when this
function is small that means the
correlation between the spins are also
small
uh yeah so
this this is uh our results about the
relation between complex zeros and if
you have correlations we we don't have
the other direction
uh so we don't know uh if uh decay of
correlation
implies that the absence of zeros
uh and as i said this is known
classically but uh there are various
problems in the
quantum case uh and they're mostly about
like
the boundary conditions so in quantum
settings the boundary
uh could be an entangled state and
you can't reduce uh so one thing that
that is common for a class called sma
system is if you have like a
boundary which are like you fix
certain spins uh in your graph
you can without loss of generality you
think that
you've done that by flipping spins one
by one so you can look at how the system
changes
uh as you fix spins one by one so this
this view doesn't work uh
for quantum systems because uh as i said
there
the entanglement makes this picture of
individual spins being in
specific states uh to collapse
so uh so question sorry uh one more
sure yeah so so in the definition of
coalition detail that you're using so
the
the pre-factors the um the norms of oa
and ob that can scale as the size of a
and b uh
[Music]
yeah so you can right yeah so you can
think of this o
a and ob as hermitian
uh matrices with norm less than one if
you want to like edit out these
um so i was wondering
so what i was wondering is if if a
if so a b are just spins or they can get
subspace so
i was thinking of like point to set
versus point-to-point correlation so
so this is like a point-to-point
relation not point to set
uh no region a and b can contain various
spins and as you said the these uh
these norms are of our their
of order uh the size of region a and b
okay okay okay okay thanks
uh all right so so far i've talked about
the
fischer zeros but we've also looked at
the
young zero
so the idea here is that we don't need
to only
uh restrict ourselves to beta as a
parameter and like
taylor expand with respect to that we
can also
extrapolate with respect to other
parameters in the hamiltonian
uh so this can be done for a specific
family of quantum
hamiltonians called ferromagnetic
heisenberg model for the hamiltonian
uh is this thing i've written here which
is x and y and these are the same things
in the introductory slides i had
but we also have these local uh
z matrices assigned to each vertex these
are like the similar to
what we have in icing model they're like
local fields
and the parameter that we we're going to
taylor expand with is just uh
the coefficient in front of these local
terms so as long as the interactions
satisfy this property of
uh the z zz interactions be greater than
the ones for x
x and y y we call this the ferromagnetic
system
so instead of looking at complex beta
plane you can now look
at complex new plane and in order to uh
do taylor expansion again you need to
know where these complex zeros are
and this can be done by mapping this
system to
a classical spin system and looking at
the complex zeros of that system so this
has been done by
suzuki and fisher and they've shown that
the
the complex zeros are all on the
imaginary axis
so now that we know the location of
complex zeros of
the classical spin system we can go back
to the quantum one
and directly taylor expand uh
the quantum partition function so you
can show that
for this specific hamiltonian the
partition function
is a polynomial in terms of e to the mu
and you basically start from large value
of mu where finding the derivatives
uh can be done in quasi-polynomial time
and then
extrapolate to some constant but
non-zero value of mu
so previously there was a polynomial
time algorithm
for a similar model called for a
magnetic xy model
so this one doesn't have those zzz terms
that i had in the previous slide but
this is still ferromagnetic
and this is by bravian gossip and the
the way
the algorithm works is again by
mapping the quantum partition function
to a classical counting problem which is
counting the number of perfect matchings
of a specific graph
and then you can apply algorithms by
germa sinclair to
to estimate the classical partition
function and hence get a
approximation for the quantum right
so i think i mentioned a few times that
there is this way of mapping quantum
partition functions to
classical spin systems for certain
family of hamiltonian
i'll briefly tell you how this works
this is called like trotter expansion
and it's again another way of getting
rid of this non-commutativity of the
terms
so we start with the partition function
it's like
trace of e to the sum of these uh
local matrices and then we trivially
just divide the exponent by n and then
takes the n power so nothing has changed
but then uh since the exponent
is now the it has a one over n uh factor
if n is large enough it's polynomial in
the number of spins
uh then you can basically uh replace
into the sum of uh terms as a product of
uh
exponential matrix exponentials
uh and then you again have the nth power
uh so this kind of get allows you to
write the quantum partition function as
a sum of positive terms
and uh for certain hamiltonians uh
the the thing that you get at the end
looks like
the partition function of a classical
system so there are
uh some subtleties here one is that
this only works for a certain
hamiltonian uh in general you just get a
classical spin system with
complex uh interactions
and one other thing is that if you start
with a certain graph
uh in the quantum part uh
what this spin system that you get
by this structure expansion is uh it has
like uh it's in one higher dimension so
you basically
take your original graph and stack it uh
n times because of this power of n here
uh you stack these graphs on top of each
other and that's uh
that's your uh graph for the the speed
system
uh and one other thing is that the
system that uh you get at the end
uh it has uh coefficients on the edges
that depends on the number of the spins
uh
in the quantum problem so some of the
coefficients grow
logarithmically with the number of the
spins
some of the other interactions in the
same uh smoothness system
shrink as the inverse polynomial so it's
not like a
generic class called spin system that
people are studying tcs
but uh some of the sampling algorithms
that
exist can already handle uh
such delicate dispense systems so this
is like uh for example has been done for
this
perfect matching thing uh
so yeah i think uh that's basically all
i had to
i wanted to say so there are some open
questions
as i said the picture uh we have her
quantum is consistent that is still
very incomplete uh we don't have the
equivalent of various uh
results for classical spin systems yet
in particular it would be nice to
have a stronger results on the complex
zeros their connection with correlation
decay or get just better algorithms
for quantum partition functions one
other thing is that i think this is like
a good opportunity for
people to in tcs to apply their uh
toolkits to solve quantum problems by
using this mapping so
normally as i said the the classical
spin models that you get
via these mappings is not like something
that is motivated by itself so people
probably haven't studied in the past
but uh maybe
uh the same techniques that uh that are
that already exist
uh for conventional spin models can be
extended to this system
uh so i i talked about how a
quantum partition function can be mapped
to class gaussian systems but
there are also other quantum problems
that you can analyze by looking at the
spin models and these come from
quantum circuits so you can i don't get
into the details but you can look at
these papers the
basic idea is that you can map the
output probabilities of quantum circuits
to
a partition function of spin models with
complex interactions
so there are recent results for studying
these uh
spin models with complex interactions it
would be nice to
uh apply them uh to these uh to these
quantum problems all right so with that
i'll
finish my tag these are the references
and thank you
questions
um this is one uh question
sorry yet again so um so the so the
depression sloshman condition
um yeah so yeah so it's uh so it
requires some kind of slow growth of the
graph right
like uh the graph should not be growing
too fast like so i mean they estimate it
for lattice but you can
yeah so so does your it does your result
also is
your your your result that the
uh that uh zero freeness implies
correlation
also required yeah it does because of
this trace a
like the oa scaling as the size i think
uh yeah yeah so
uh the results that i presented they
almost all of them work for uh bounded
degree graphs or like
uh like there is this uh notion of like
uh as you said the small
uh growth of graphs which basically uh
asks how
uh for any spin how many interactions or
how many edges are
uh connected to it uh or like if you
have a high
hyper graph hyper interaction graph then
the similar uh
condition also for our results are going
to apply to that
this is like uh what you're asking is
that
so if if the graph is like the greek
fashion is a lattice if you when you
look at a distance l they're only
only like like the number of uh
neighbors that you have is growing it
grows polynomially
whereas in a random graph it grows
exponentially in l and
and uh is in the correlation degree
condition that you had because of this
uh dependence upon o a if uh if the
distance
itself like at distance d if the number
if the size the
the norm of o itself is going
exponentially uh
so then you don't get full correlation
to get it so it's in those graphs you
don't but in latin structures
right right so okay so this is so yeah
so so because the duration slushman i
think also has the same restriction
that it requires this and so the same
restriction goes over here
as well yeah so uh i mean even uh
yeah as i said uh we we still
uh can't get exactly the same though
russian schlossman result
even with that limitation because we
assume that
these beams need to be at least
logarithmically far away from each other
uh so we can remove it yeah
but as soon as you get login you start
getting exponential decay from there
so correct it's like sort of so there is
a factor of
n in front of the the oh okay
uh and classically you can remove that
by using markov property
as i said quantumly that just breaks
any other questions
okay thanks again to all the speakers
today we're gonna be continuing tomorrow
have a good rest of the day bye